now when i
learned after reading about galileo's
descriptions of the discoveries that he
made centuries earlier he had done the
exact same thing i had done turned it to
the brightest things in the sky
jupiter
saturn he didn't turn into the sun
but the moons of jupiter were his
timepieces his celestial diamonds
i had done the same thing as the great
galileo now of course it wasn't that i
was originating these discoveries of
course he made them hundreds of years
earlier but i had the exact same
visceral experience i'm convinced that
the great maestro did as well
and of course it was cute that there was
a connection between the maestro and
myself that we were both supported in
some sense by venetian patrons his the
doge and senate of venice and mine the
venice delhi and i wanted to emulate
galileo in every way possible
except for that final last chapter of
home imprisonment and semi threats of
being tortured
let's avoid that and even at that time
in 1984 galileo had never been even
issued a formal apology he still hasn't
been pardoned by the catholic church
but at least in the late 80s early 90s
pope john paul did issue a statement
that he was correct if not actually
pardoning him working on the dialogue
with these phenomenal educators frank
fabiola carla luccio and jim gates
working with them really reminds me of
what the word educate really means
the word educate comes from the latin
phrase educare
i think fabiola could do a better job
pronouncing it than i can
but that word means to bring out of not
to pour into
we educators are always searching for
ways to enhance the learning process
to make it more visceral more resonant
with our students in order to bring out
the best within them imagine if you
could replicate the thrill the visceral
excitement that the physicists at the
large hadron collider including fabiola
felt when they discovered the higgs
boson particle in 2012. you actually
didn't have a single discovery event
but you couldn't even do that unless you
happen to have a spare 10 billion or so
lying around and then you could roll
your own lhc
but i doubt that's true for you
certainly wasn't true for me
and yet for fifty dollars you can get
your own telescope and you yourself can
replicate the feeling of discovery
that galileo felt over 400 years ago
how often is that possible in science
it's a very rare experience to have a
connection in history between the first
discoverer of something and a student
and best of all if you do that if you go
out and buy a telescope for you or for
your own children
you and i can be connected as well
feeling the same feelings that i felt
which is what i strive for in
communicating the deep impact that
astronomy has had on me and we'll share
it as two astronomers it doesn't matter
if you're professional or not
once you unlock the mysteries of the
cosmos through a small telescope you'll
be able to be bonded with all the
astronomers throughout history you'll
become a universal voyager just like me
so parents any parents out there go out
there and buy a telescope for a kid in
your life or just get one for you
you can see the exact same objects
galileo saw 400 years ago even from the
middle of manhattan
you can see the craters on the moon the
rings of saturn the moons of jupiter the
phases of venus and millions of other
phenomena one day i'll start my own
keating brand telescope company because
i've probably sold more telescopes to
parents and friends around the world
that isaac newton himself what's it
going to take to get you into a keating
brand star spotter 2000 i'll include
simonizing and undercoating and i'll
throw in these wheeled tripods for free
remember abc always be curious or is it
always be closing basically take the
telescope out as soon as you get it read
the instructions put it together and
point it at the first bright object you
see in the sky but not the sun okay
that's my only disclaimer warning do not
look at the sun with your remaining eye
i want you to be able to watch my into
the impossible videos for decades to
come
so there you have it that's how i went
from a pimple face pudge ball to a
professor from a dweeb and dobbs ferry
to a star seeker at the south pole from
being a shy introverted pre-teen to
getting to hang out on captain kirk's
unexplained tv discussing the wonders of
the moon and it's all thanks to a tiny
little telescope that i got when i was a
kid many many decades ago and i hope you
will do the same for the child in your
life
i'll put some links to great telescopes
for any budget on my blog at
briankeating.com
just click here to access it leave a
comment in the comment section below
about how it felt when you or your child
first saw the craters on the moon
if you want to hear more about my
astronomical journey click here to see
my google talk or click here to see an
interview with some of my astronomy
buddies debating the greatest mysteries
in cosmology and astronomy today
[Music]